bonsoir à tous je suis matt a demandé à
dix chorégraphes
fille et petite-fille de matrone matrone
dans un premier temps c'est des
accoucheuses traditionnelles et un peu
plus loin ces décisions les matrones
c'est des femmes qui sont importants
dans la société c'est des femmes chez
qui on confie nos enfants pour acquérir
une sagesse c'est ce que nous savons des
matrones dans la culture africaine
j'ai été excisée à l'âge de 7 ans parce
que simplement je portais le long d'une
matrone qui est ma grand-mère pour vous
dis un peu la voyance des matrones quand
j'avais 7 ans madame 1 avait prédit que
j'allais pâtir de la côte d'ivoire à
l'âge de 15 ans puisque ça l'âge de 15
ans que l'excision se pratique chez nous
et elle avait vu juste à 15 ans j'étais
déjà dans l'avion et j'étais en tant que
danseuse en france donc pour vous parler
de mon et cision décision c'est quoi
excision pour être plus vulgaire comme
tout ce qu'on sait c'est l'ablation du
clitoris maintenant dans ma culture
l'excision sap est vu comme un passage à
l'âge adulte
l'excision c'est aussi une grosse fête
ou familles enfants entrent tout le
monde me fait plaisir à leur petite
fille les cision dans ma culture
il ya des femmes ou des filles qui
attendent comme un jour de noël et
l'excision
c'est aussi cette douleur que nous avons
tous en commun quelles que soient les
raisons pour lesquelles on pratiquer
l'excision
cette douleur atroce cette
incompréhension avec tous en boucle tout
cet engouement autour de toi ou tu te
sens comme une princesse un essai plein
de cadeaux
cette douleur que tu reçois le jour où
tu oses ou aux décisions et pratiquer
cette douleur qu'on ne peut pas
expliquer où tu as l'impression de tuer
tout le monde où tu te sens trahi
quelques secondes et après cette douleur
quel que soit le lieu où ça a été quand
tu regardes le visage de ces femmes qui
sont autour des toits qui viennent
d'être fait si mal
tu sens en u15 aussi pleuré que toi
parce que pour elle dans l'ignorance et
pensent des pense que tu dois devenir
comme elles et elles sont soulagées que
tu n'es pas y reste tu n'es pas rester
là donc quelque part les cision pour
vous expliquer aujourd'hui je vais vous
dire tout simplement les cision ses
douleurs c'est un acte de bravoure
parce que quand tu lis dans les yeux
c'est comme si tu devenais comme elle
comme si tu appartenait à une tribu des
femmes qui détiennent pourtant dans une
société
j'en passe ça c'est quand j'avais 7 ans
j'arrive en france attend que atys
chorégraphe donc je monte une
association mon objectif c'était pas
d'aborder lutter contre l'excision avec
tout ce que je vous explique
dans ma tête c'est qu'elle a lutté ce
n'était pas mon objectif premier
c'était déjà de me faire connaître en
tant que danseuse et chose que j'ai fait
je me suis fait connaître à rennes et un
jour y avait une conférence je suis
juste eu à la mairie et on m'a dit en
conférence une décision quelque part ça
m'a interpellé
parce qu'être fille et petite-fille des
matrones quelque part entre attend et
cision ça te parle et là moi je vais
tout simplement à cette conférence
comme tout le monde et là j'arrive à la
conférence je pense que c'est là que
tout a basculé
j'arrive à cette conférence j'écoute et
tous les maux que j'entends franchement
je ne me reconnais pas je reconnais pas
l'excision que j'avais dans ma tête
cette définition des décisions parce que
c'était considéré comme un crime
c'était dans la salle il y avait des
biens y avait des sujets comme ces
femmes qui font ça à leurs enfants
c'était sauvage pour moi je me suis
sentie blessée
je me suis senti humilié je me suis
sentie
salle à cette conférence parce que ma
mère qui m'a et 6 et à 7 ans n'étaient
pas une criminelle ni ma grande mais ni
ce que j'avais vu dans le visage de ces
femmes mais je reste quand même
patienter je me dis à la fin je vais pas
me poser de questions à la dent pourquoi
est ce que elle elle atténue tels propos
jaurès et plus tard je vois que j'ai eu
raison parce que dans cette même
conférence
j'ai découvert elle a dit aussi des
choses qui ont fait que je me suis
retrouvé en tant que femme là dans les
accouchements difficiles la foule sur
les rapports non désirées les douleurs
que nous avons donc je suis sorti de
cette conférence mitigé pour vous dit
voilà en quoi l'europe m'a permis
d'avancer dans quelque chose je suis
sorti révolté et en même temps une prise
de conscience donc c'était pas si
mauvais maintenant je me dis il faut
faire quelque chose
si tout les mots dans lesquels tu te
retrouves aujourd'hui ça veut dire que
dans ta dans ta communauté
il ya beaucoup de femmes qui sont comme
toi mais qui n'ont pas cette possibilité
de se retrouver eux dans l'europe ou
d'un système conférences et vu comment
cette conférence a été a démarré avec le
côté brutal
je pense pas que une femme dé ma région
pouvait rester jusqu'à la fin donc il
faut lutter hautement parce que quand on
parle des traditions il ya une
frustration qui fait que l'on ferme les
oreilles on n'a plus envie d'aller plus
loin et je pense que l'ouverture que
l'europe m'a donné c'est ce qui a fait
que malgré ma frustration j'ai pu rester
sur place jusqu'à la fin donc lutter
autrement comment là je me retrouve avec
moi même et je vais me battre contre moi
même vous savez le tabou c'est important
il ya des gens qui écrivent des livres
l'excision on lutte contre l'excision
depuis des décennies ça finit pas mais
le plus gros des trucs c'est cette
pratique est le tabou moi j'avais décidé
dé lutter mais je n'avais pas les âmes
parce que j'avais de l'ain
si on détruit ma famille même parler de
douleur devant les gens pour moi c'était
comme si je réalisais les gens dont je
ne pouvais pas j'avais envie de lutter
mais je savais pas comment il faut
lutter et l ut il suffit pas de dire je
lui dis je lutte tu luttes mais qu'est
ce que tu mets en place donc une
réflexion je me suis mis à réfléchir et
je dis moi je vais lutter mais sans
tesson changé en tout cas je vais lutter
dans la tolérance et à partir de là plus
que je ne pouvais pas parler je me suis
dit je vais créer un spectacle qui va me
permet de faire des sensibilisations et
aussi toucher un public ici parce que en
europe les cision était déjà comme un
crime et du coup il ya une partie de la
population qui se sent pas dedans et du
coup les cision continue dans les
villages et en france on est avertis
mais dans les villages on n'est pas à
betty donc avec ce spectacle géorgie a
touché mes bénévoles géorgie a fait
comprendre un peu mais sachant que ça
n'a pas été facile parce qu'on me
prenait dans un premier temps pour
quelqu'un qui voulait que l'excision
continue et non c'était pas ça il
fallait juste lutte et dans le respect
des gens pour moi les gens dans les
villages n'étaient pas assez avait tissé
pourquoi décisions continuent donc après
cette période ça a duré quatre ans je me
dis maintenant que j'ai des bénévoles
il faut y aller sur le terrain pour voir
comment est ce que on peut changer les
choses là bas parce que ici on est
avertis mais ce temps que là bas ça
change pas l'excision n'y va jamais
s'arrêter
donc je fais un premier voyage chez moi
la première fois et là je me suis rendu
compte que je ne m'étais pas trompé
parce que l'excision était encore au
centre de toutes les conversations
et moi j'avais quitté mon village depuis
l'âge de 17 ans donc si aujourd'hui on
milite i en france en europe à tout ça
faisait ça fait déjà 30 ans et que
l'excision il ya 100 % des femmes qui
sont excisées encore chez moi ça veut
dire que quelque part le message il
n'est pas passé
ça veut dire quelque part les gens
concernés ne sont pas avertis
donc je me suis dit je vais pas les
communistes infitah deyn qui dit je suis
quitte enfants
je vais changer les choses d'abord
premier objectif rassembler des femmes
créé une association d aide aux femmes
diminuent simplement ou ya matrone où il
ya des acolytes les acolytes c'est un
peu comme les aides soignantes auprès
des infirmiers ou ou des sages femmes
donc j'ai dit sages-femmes et les
matrones les acolytes toutes les classes
d'âge qui ne se mélangent pas dans les
communautés il faut les mélanges et déjà
pour casser un mythe
parce que on parle pas incision avec les
plus jeunes donc il fallait casser
quelque chose et cette association les
femmes les matins non acceptés pour une
première fois
dette dans la même catégorie que toutes
les femmes du village
ça c'était pour moi ma première victoire
et je l'avais dit on va essayer de créer
une association je vais rentrer en
france j'ai pas d'argent mais on essaie
de demander des subventions quand je
suis rentré j'ai dit à mes bénévoles
on commence maintenant on a dansé en
france maintenant il va falloir aller
sur le terrain
donc là il faut qu'on cherche des
subventions ça va être difficile pour
que l'on soit soutenir parce que j'aime
notre discours sur décision je parle du
respect de la tradition et en europe
s'est vu comme un crime
donc il va falloir conserver six dans un
premier temps si on veut que ça change
là bas donc les choses ont commencé les
bénévoles ont commencé aussi à payer
leur transport
le billet d'avion comme moi et on a
demandé des subventions on investit dans
le premier projet de aide aux femmes
donc les apolit elles ont commencé le
premier travail ce qui a motivé d'autres
femmes deuxième deuxième volet du projet
il fallait absolument pour moi que je
touche maintenant les marolles parce que
mon objectif c'était les matrones
deuxième volet j'ai dû au mcs rome
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'excision
qu'est ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
dans notre communauté de l'arrêt de
l'excision qui a été décidé par l'état
parce que l'état est un deal excision
mais au fait les gens ne vont pas sur le
terrain pour militer parce qu'ils ont
peuvent justement de la puissance de ces
femmes parce que c'est des femmes aussi
condé connaissance des plantes et des
femmes aussi qu'ils sont si mystique
dont ainsi que les tapis etc qui est sur
le terrain ça fait deux donc je pose la
question pour ne pas que ça vienne de
moi et là les matrones ça a été comme
ça a été pas me une boule l on s était
frustré et monde et vous voyez ma fille
il ya cinquante la 60 et unique en côte
d'ivoire pourquoi il ne s'attaque pas à
la tradition des autres pourquoi est ce
que il trouve que nous on pratiquer
l'excision et qu' on n'a pas
d'explication
ils veulent simplement ils nous mettent
en prison ils nous mettent en plus on
met ça n'arrête pas parce que nous et
nos traditions
ils m'ont expliqué tout ce qui les
poussait et l'éducation de nos enfants
parce que nous les cision c'est la
partie où on passe aussi le message d
éducation de nos enfants nos traditions
ou esquiver le m moi j'ai discuté tout
ça comme si j'étais un peu bête je les
écoute et je dis bon mais moi je crois
en sa et moi j'étais assise et je suis
l'exemple même qu'une décision n'est pas
bête mais tôt ou tard les cision va
s'arrêter de manière brutale parce que
tout le monde entier veut que l'excision
ça arrête
soit on s'est mis ensemble on valorise
vos connaissances des plantes vous
devenez des accoucheuses ont fait une
formation est on est on laisse à votre
côté qui est important dans les
communautés parce que vous restez des
femmes importantes aujourd'hui une femme
africaine qui passent dans la mer deux
matrones ressort gagnante là dedans
parce que tu as l'éducation français et
tu as l'éducation aussi africaines parce
qu'on en a besoin
donc moi mon objectif n'est pas de vous
dire aujourd'hui d'arrêter décision mais
c'est de travailler ensemble des tests
lorsque l'on tourne la solution comment
est-ce qu'on va garder cette tradition
sans menace de couper le clitoris tu es
quelqu'un donc ma première conversation
et les matrones synthé ça dont je leur
ai dit en ce moment moi je vais vous
envoyer des sages femmes qui vont vous
formez déjà pour être accouchée chose
qui n'était pas gagné parce que une
matrone accoucheuses et une matrone et 6
2 la matrone est 6e à plus de grade que
matrone accoucheuses les choses qui a
été acceptée donc je rentre en france
mattel a filé de fait bon je vais vous
former mais n'est parfois pas très sain
dont j'arrive en france et là je
commence à faire des conférences avec
docteur haricots parce que je donne
aussi des conférences avec eux d'un jury
j'ai réparateur pour expliquer un peu
l'importance de l'es6
et puis comme il faut s'y prendre avec
les autres donc on va à l'école de
sages-femmes à pontchaillou
le but c'est d'apprendre à ces femmes là
qu'elle compta paix peuvent avoir avec
les femmes excisées
et là je fais nouvelle rencontre claudie
rebelles qui enseigne que des sages
femmes
on s'est rencontré et trois mois après
elle m'a suivi en côte d'ivoire donc ça
c'est prime deuxième victoire
j'avais une formatrice mais une vraie
donc on arrive en côte d'ivoire est la
première formation jeudi à claudie
claudie tu fais la formation mais dans
un premier temps tu n'es pas et 6 et u
et blanche
il faut qu'on gagne la confiance des
matrones on parle pas et cision tu fait
primer formation on rend en france et
après on va préparer le terrain est du
hockey on arrive on fait la formation
donc les matrones sont motivés il y
avait il y avait 20 il y avait dix
matrone deuxième formation
on en avait 50 et pendant sa peau
pendant l'essai que pendant qu'il ya eu
les 50 j'ai profité pour lui à dit comme
vous faites des accouchements dans les
cases et tout ça et qu'on n'a pas des
lieux des sensibilisations ça sera bien
qu'on vous fasse une case des marolles
parce qu'une maternité c'est la
concurrence au corps médical mais une
case des matrones dans tous les villages
les matrones akkouche qui lie à un lieu
ou pas qu'il y à une maternité ou pas il
ya des femmes qui sont assises et qui
n'ont pas envie qu'une femme qui n'est
pas et 6 et qui a eu tous les diplômes
les touches
donc vaut mieux vous donnez à pour vous
et un endroit où on peut vous
sensibiliser et en même temps vous
permettre de faire des accouchements
dans les gènes
et là je pense que ça a été le truc qui
a tout changé dans le village les
matrones ont accepté ça comme si c'était
sa 10ème le projet et elles ont
participé à ça et après on a décidé
ensemble les matrones qui allait
travailler dans cette maternité devait
plus assise et donc on avait vingt
matrone elles ont choisi d'y matrone
pour l'instant qui travaillent dans
cette maternité qui pratiquent plus du
tout les 6 y ont donc j'ai profité su ça
et j'ai dit bon pendant le temps qu'on
négocie puisque c'est négociations je
veux pas là
faux c'est parce que tout ce que nous
avons fait pour qu'il nous donne 9,9
matrone et les acolytes qui ont arrêté
de pratiquer l'excision
on les a pas mis en prison je les ai
jamais insulté et pendant les formations
on les a sensibilisés sans qu'on le
fasse une réunion de sensibilisation
c'est dans la formation que tout est
passé j'adhère claudie tu fais passer
toutes les transmissions et du coup
elles vont se rendre compte petit à
petit que il y a il ya un sujet parce
qu'il faut pas casser centrum des gens
qui sont qui sont agressés et selon plus
prête à nous écouter et ça ça a marché
parce qu'elles ont commencé à comparer
les matrones qui meurt pour la tension
la transmission dans notre région il ya
120 il ya femmes toutes les femmes
meurent du vih mais personne ne fait
allusion à la pratique décision on a le
taux le plus élevé du vih cheveux et
elles ont commencé à se poser cette
question là
donc pour moi aujourd'hui quand je vous
pas de changer les choses changer une
tradition c'est de proposer quelque
chose
un changement s'est déformée accompagné
des jambes dans le changement pas dans
le préjugé parce que ces femmes là elles
étaient frustrés depuis des décennies et
du coup ça faisait que l'excision était
de venir
il attendait plus 14 ans mais c'était
maintenant l'âge de 7 ans 8 ans qui
pratiquer l'excision dans le village par
la peur de la police ou du gouvernement
qui qu'ils pouvaient faire des
arrestations
donc maintenant l'excision suffisait de
manière massive et là aujourd'hui
elles sont au courant des conséquences
mais sans se sentir blessé et petit à
petit des choses peuvent changer vite
pour moi petit à petit et c'est de faire
comprendre les choses aux gens et ne pas
rester sur les préjugés
donc aujourd'hui l'association parraine
des enfants et ce avec l'accord de tout
le village que ça soit chef du village
station à main et paix ils vous donnent
des enfants comprennent et en retour ces
enfants sont 1,6 et au moins six
personnes jugées et il n'y a pas de
litige entre les familles parce que ce
qui est dangereux dans cette tradition
c'est que si tu montes le fils contre la
mer après c'est tout problème que ça
crée il faut regarder aussi ce passage à
l'âge adulte
vous gardez le passage qui fait de moi
aujourd'hui une citadelle mais qui a un
autre regard sur le monde
cette sagesse là moi j'aimerais que ma
fille stéphanie et l'esa j'aimerais que
ma fille soit précisée mais qu'elle soit
passée dans pas dans la mer des matrones
et avec ce projet les matrones pourront
donner ce passage à l'âge adulte sans
passer par l'âge du clitoris de couper
le clitoris je préfère est une brute
plus comme ça parce que c'est comme ça
qu'il faut l'appeler parce que c'est
suite à cela que l'on peut pas accepter
on y verra alors qu'on peut avoir tout
ce qui est bien tout ce qui est positif
là-dedans ce passage là on peut le fait
hautement suis tout ce qu'on appelle les
traditions j'ai envie de garder le côté
festif de l'excision garder le côté
connaissance des plantes les valoriser
pour que les matrones rsa leur place et
que la communauté africaine puisse
acquis sa tradition et capi puisse avoir
des changements à long terme voilà et je
voulais partager une chanson qui
m'interpelle tout ce que j'ai envie de
garder de l'excision
un trisomique épisode hadopi c'est fini
pison
oh
ackermann et beauté les bons mots des
mots ont capoté parce qu'il mord et
sofia et amassant qui s'en prenaient au
pape à tokyo